since ancient times there's been the
belief that all creation follows a
mathematical pattern like Phi or the
golden ratio
is there really such a sacred formula
that rules over everything
[Music]
they crashed into one of the towers
[Applause]
thank you
I was born with a thing for mathematics
numbers just fit my mind easily
through them that I understand the world
and I believe that mathematics is the
best language for everything
it's like music
both possess me and I become a vehicle
through which numbers and notes are
expressed
I love that feeling of being part of
something bigger
so this idea about the ratio for
everything does seem appealing to me but
is it real
just the act of doing geometry is a form
of prayer it has a philosophical and
symbolical dimension to it yeah
is there such a unique Ratio or is it
just a myth that we have been telling
ourselves to make sense of what
surrounds us
and is it true that human behavior is
ruled by formulas which are easy to
decipher and predict its results
[Music]
she shows us that thousands of years ago
in ancient Egypt
our ancestors built their temples
following sacred ratios that they
believed connected us to the divine
to the whole universe
and not only in Egypt
in my research I have repeatedly come
across the concept of the golden ratio
in different cultures
which is one thing all these old
buildings have in common
thing of the past
in order to understand more I decided to
start from the clearest application of
cosmic or sacred geometry from the Arts
I met Dana alertani a visual artist who
actually uses geometry and these
proportions in her art
hi Dana how are you hi Hamed it's nice
to meet you I'm good how do you express
sacred geometry and the golden ratio in
your work sacred geometry is one of the
main focal points in my artwork
um you know what I try to do is take
sacred geometry to kind of just
appreciate the art form on its own for
what it is so when I went to London to
study Arts you know I was one of the
only Arab students on the course you
know there was this very negative sort
of orientalistic perspective towards who
I am and my identity so I wanted to
learn more about my culture my identity
and sacred geometry is used a lot within
Islam so I just started you know
exploring it on my own and I fell in
love with it so where can we find sacred
geometry apart from art sacred geometry
I would say is the study of numbers in
three-dimensional form that is related
to the principles of the universe and
principles found in nature so really if
you look at sacred geometry it's a way
of praising the cosmos praising nature
through form basically
so art uses these proportions because
Nature has done that first you can find
sacred geometry from a microcosmic all
the way up to a macrocosmic level
throughout nature so from the way the
planets move around the solar system you
know they create pentagons the design if
you look at snowflakes under a
microscope hexagonal designs if you look
at beehives that's also six-fold
geometry you know a lot of plants are
based on five-fold Geometry which is the
golden ratio your own DNA is you know
there's geometry in that so do you
actually think that sacred geometry and
the golden ratio are connecting people
in a spiritual way oh absolutely I think
sacred geometry is a form of
spirituality you know it's a form of
remembrance it's a form of prayer
because when you do geometry when you're
actually drawing it you need to be fully
focused you need to be in the right
State of Mind you cannot be angry you
cannot be stressed you have it consumes
you fully
so the golden ratio isn't man-made
but discovered in the repeated
geometrical patterns found in nature
and it is just simply expressed in
architecture and art
all my life whenever I play music I feel
that I am not composing
I am merely copying some tunes I hear in
my head
is this the effect of the golden ratio
on me or am I going mad
finding these proportions in the Arts
that our man-made is one thing
but seeing them in the world around us
is not the same
where are these ratios and if they exist
and draw shapes
and shapes are a type of natural
phenomenon can we say that they cover
natural phenomena
can we say that it affects our human
behavior
the numbers say that it is true that
there are patterns everywhere in nature
this is what all laws of sacred geometry
come from
natural patterns and many of these
patterns affect our lives
summer winter day and night
I would like to talk to someone who
knows more about this someone who
Masters numbers and patterns in nature
Randall Carlson master builder and
architectural designer teacher
geometrician
geomithologist and geological Explorer
has spent four decades studying the
relationship between ancient Mysteries
and modern science
hi Randall thank you very much for
taking the time to talk to me all right
what is sacred geometry or Cosmic
geometry or whatever it is referred to
as I do tell people that you know if
you're going to embark on a study of
sacred geometry you've got to realize
that it has a philosophical and
symbolical dimension to it I guess you
could say that that's the primary
difference between sacred geometry and
regular euclidean geometry where can we
feel it in nature it's about Harmony
it's about the compatibility of various
forms and patterns and forces in nature
so one of the key tenets of sacred
geometry is that of scale invariance the
part represents the geometry and the
proportions of the whole why did ancient
civilizations use it much more than we
use it nowadays well because they seem
to have the awareness that they could
achieve certain shall we say
psychological or emotional states
through the use of geometry but I think
that there might be another level to it
it yields Harmony and Beauty on a level
that is almost palpable that you can
almost feel when we look at some of the
extraordinary mosaic tile work in many
of the mosques we see sacred geometry at
work but on top of that I think there's
actually a kind of a resonance
amplification of energy that a person
who's undergoing a spiritual discipline
can actually be aware of do you think
sacred geometry can influence human
behavior into a pattern
that is predictable you know there says
that Robert Proctor who years ago wrote
a book explaining how he used the
Fibonacci sequence to make stock market
predictions and I think he had a pretty
high rate of success using it I
certainly do think that if we begin to
utilize the principles of Harmony in the
cultural world that we create around us
it's going to have a beneficial effect
on our psyche I think that there is
there's a crying need now for our
recovery in the resurrection of the
ancient system
uh and it's a very powerful tool for
achieving Harmony and balance and
symmetry in the world around us
our ancestors were contemplating the
world around them in an attempt to
predict the future
today we think that we are better
and that we regard ourselves as more
developed but is it possible for example
that the ancient human societies were
seeing and knowing things that we
neither see nor know today
is it really as Carlson says
that the golden ratio connects
everything in the universe
is it possible that there is a
similarity or connection between Birds
stars and humans that is deeper than
what we see
is there a mathematical logic in human
behavior
and what about people who claim they
profit from stock markets by predicting
prices according to the golden ratio
part of me wants to believe this is true
and that everything in the universe is
linked to a system and equations
maybe there are some we know already
today and a lot more we don't
but Another Part Of Me tells me no
that human behavior is the product of
the moment and it is not really possible
to predict and any resemblance between
human behavior geometric patterns and
the golden ratio is an exaggeration or
it could be a self-fulfilling prophecy
this is the part that makes me
unsatisfied with linking the golden
ratio to human behavior
[Music]
if there is a big enough number of
people convinced with this golden ratio
you will find that they are trying to
achieve it in their behavior
the problem is that I now have two
different opinions and both seem
convincing
I think it is great for us to discover
something like the golden ratio and the
Beautiful shapes and all of that and I
see as well that we have to live in
harmony with nature
but the story that it controls my
behavior does not convince me I say you
should see the people that will put
money in this why are they doing this
for sure they gain a lot of money doing
that
[Music]
oh
to believe this theory is one thing
but to literally bet your money on it is
another thing entirely
is a journalist in Social economics a
producer TV presenter Business
Development consultant and part-time
lecturer
maybe he can help me know more about the
ratios they apply in the stock market
foreign
[Music]
examples
whatever
foreign
watching the stars in the sky at night
and getting to know the way they rotate
observing the birds and the proportions
formed by their flocks
examining the plants and their geometric
patterns
it is more than curiosity and a desire
for discovery
it is more like a kind of meditation
meditation on the golden ratio opens the
door to a larger and more important
question if human behavior is in some
way governed by this does this mean that
a person does not have free will
in my personal opinion a person is born
with his choices
these choices are in harmony with the
laws of the universe and its proportions
it simply means that the golden ratio is
a call to a unified harmony with all
creatures in the universe
and whether you accept this invitation
or not
is entirely your own choice
[Music]
oh